it is pretty amazing there is this whole
controversy we talked about it yesterday
on the show in Canada over a feminist
named Megan Murphy she has a speech and
it's Wiranto library in which she
maintained that men are men and women
are women I know
huge huge news hundreds of protesters
showed up the mayor of Toronto condemned
the library for allowing her to speak so
many on the Left would like libraries
not to sponsor speeches by feminists who
say that men should not be able to enter
women's restrooms or women's locker
rooms but libraries are praised for
holding drag queen story hour even if
things go wildly wrong there's a blogger
named Ann Taylor she's writing a
caffeinated thoughts she attended in
October 17th events at Hennepin County
Country library and shared photos online
of a drag queens exposed crotch
according to Taylor a drag queen showed
up to read to small preschool children
wearing a sleeveless cutoff t-shirt
resembling SpongeBob SquarePants with
midriff exposed a pink miniskirt rainbow
ankle socks a black spiked heel that
went above six inches the wiki war was
mermaid-style crimping in the color of
bright orange and makeup that was far
too much under the neon lights the drag
queen strode insisted leap assed the
children sitting down in a chair before
several preschool aged girls with his
legs spread wide exposing his nylon
covered crotch in front of children
sitting at eye level we noticed he did
this often while reading nervously
before the children there are some 20
plus adults in attendance some of the
fathers were there she said quickly left
after they saw the performer themselves
there are about 22 children ranging in
age from infants and toddlers into
elementary school so just to make clear
what the left would like no speeches of
libraries about men being men and women
being women no raising your child to be
a boy if he at any point expresses that
he believes he's a girl remove the child
from the home and also very good to have
events at libraries with sexualized drag
queens parading themselves in front of
small children who don't understand what
the hell is going on does this seem kind
of perverse to you maybe because it's
pretty perverse maybe because it's
exploitation of children this is not
about the protection of the innocence of
children or making children open-minded
when you are utilizing sexualized
imagery in order to twist children to a
political point of view and use them as
props that is not to the benefit of
children by the way the Hennepin country
Library County Library told the blaze
that the program is
we knew and is unfortunately making
mistakes who could have foreseen who
could have foreseen